item i have from fulton county is they
have 3 900 provisionals i do not know
the coding on those provisionals
as you may or may not know depending on
the coding there has to be actions done
by the voter
or there is an automatic acceptance of
those ballots again depending on the
coding of those and i do not have that
detail
um gwinnett is down to 4 800. that was a
we had discussions with them about what
that why they had the 7 700 out there
part of that is just a scanning
differential between
the accepted ballots and those were
reported so their actual total is
about 4 400 of the absentee ballots to a
new absentee ballots to scan and report
and they did have an issue that was
asked about earlier this morning
they had a corrupt memory card on one of
the early voting
icps the polling place scanners they
discovered that
they took the ballots from that they
rescanned those and those will be
included the totals it's approximately
400 votes
and that is included in the 4 800. but
that's one of the
benefits of having a paper backup is
that you could if those situations occur
you can take care of those harris is
continuing to work
lawrence county we talked to them this
afternoon
and they are trying to
figure out exactly where the batches are
for the 797 because they had thought
they had uploaded them and they looked
and realized they had not
um taylor had a unique issue
they did their absentee ballot printing
in-house
uh something along the way made the
ballots not the appropriate size
so if you have a ballot that is based on
coordinates which a hamper ballot is
and it is not the right size it cannot
be scanned so they're going through the
process of duplicating each of those
ballots
on the ballot marking devices and then
what they have to do is have to take the
original ballot and the duplicate ballot
so they can tie them together have to be
marked that each one matches to the
other one
to keep a paper trail alive with the
original artifact of the voter they will
take those
ballots and it's 456 of them
and then run them to their scanner they
are a little over halfway through that
process right now you can imagine it's
an arduous process you want to be
precise and make sure you get the
ballot reflecting exactly what the
intended vote of the voter was
so again that gets to a total of 47 277
on another note following up on another
question that was asked earlier today
we have this is included in the counts
we have right now there are 17
529 yuakava which is our military and
overseas ballots have been accepted in
the counties
and as i noted earlier under the federal
laws
the yuakov ballots that are postmarked
by tuesday can be accepted up to
tomorrow
friday so of the pool of those
there are eight thousand eight hundred
and ninety nine
that doesn't mean any of them will
arrive or it means that all of them
could arrive we have no way of knowing
that number
so as we make that clear it's not
there's 8 900 ballots to be counted
those are ones that could arrive to be
counted in any subset thereof
so with that i will answer any questions
you may have mr secretary can you tell
us
well let's see first of all not the
secretary uh
i'm the statewide building system
implementation manager
again as we've been stating for weeks
and months that with the advent of paper
it's going to take time
we anticipate having the account quote
unquote done when the legal deadline
certification is
which is going to be ten days after the
election that's when we're done because
there are ballots that are still coming
in
there are ballots to be cured there are
ballots the provisionals that are to be
verified
so we can't know how long the process
will take we hope to have clarity on the
outcomes of these elections as soon as
possible
however when you have so many important
elections in the state being so close
done it's a very relative term at this
point we're trying to get all the
legal votes counted accurately so we can
give the right results and make sure
that everybody's vote is reflected
properly
yes sir what's your message to people
around the state and around the country
who claim the amount of time it's taking
georgia is some sort of effort to steal
an election
the effort here is to make sure that
everybody's vote legal vote is counted
properly
and that the actual results are
reflective of the voters
intent the the issue we have in georgia
is like i said it's a close vote
there's other states that have more
votes to count than we do but it's a
wide margin so
nobody cares so this is the first time
we used paper ballots in this state in
20 years
so as we said you know two weeks ago
three so the secretary stood where i'm
standing and said
this is going to take a little more time
these close elections require us to be
diligent
and make sure we do everything right yes
sir
what happened uh under the law in the
states there's two different ways you
can request a recount you can request it
before
certification if you are going to allege
that there is anything specific a
regularity that has occurred
that would be a county by county
function you really we don't see a
mechanism in place to
call for a statewide uh
a statewide recount under that scenario
the second way is it would have to be
after certification and whether that's
county certification or state
certification
i would leave that to lawyers but um it
would potentially be after the state
certification
and then at that point one of the good
things we have happening today is that
we have been setting up for
our risk limiting audit and in doing
that we have what's built
are called ballot manifests where we
know the amount of ballots in each one
and they are tracked so we know exactly
how many there are and
the rule we passed to help define the
recount after we passed hb 316 which was
our election reform law
that was supported by secretary
raffensberger was that essentially
you would take a sample amount of
ballots run them through the scanner
make sure that it matched what we saw
there and then you would rescan those
ballots on these central scanners called
the icc
at each one of the counties in
anticipation of this
as i noted in our conference earlier the
secretary directed that we
procure the high-speed high-capacity
scanners
for each and every county regardless
population for just such an occasion as
this
yes
we anticipate most recounts do not make
differences and but in the past we
weren't revolving on paper on that
especially this volume of hand marks
paper
the cost unknowable unknown at this
point i couldn't give you an answer on
that one the good thing is we have
already procured the necessary equipment
statewide
for such an occasion um how long it's
going to take
it will be faster than we saw in chatham
county where a judge decided to order a
hand
hand count of the ballots we had off the
bmds it took five days to do 5 000
ballots
in this case using technology we
anticipated could take up to a week
again that's just our first blush look
at it we in fact we were talking with
some logistics companies earlier about
making sure we put processes in place
with the counties but it would have to
be after the certification in order to
make that happen yeah
follow up certified by
november 13th no the county's
certified by november 13th the state has
to certify that november 20th
and um in that process do you anticipate
um sooner than later i know you can't
guess on the contrary
what is your best guess
now here's the issue we are reliant upon
the counties to do their jobs and do
their jobs properly
we have talked we had a conference call
with all hundreds tonight counties this
afternoon led by our elections director
chris harvey
basically laying out this timeline to
them saying the sooner you get the stuff
to us the sooner that we can um
get the um your certifications on the
sooner we can get the audit done and
soon we get our certification done
so we can get that out of the way
because we need to understand a few
things about those 159 elections
directors i was talking about before we
have a potential in the state of having
a state-wide
runoff for a state level election in the
psc
that means that there will be one on
december 10th
that means they have to be prepared for
that under our state law they have a
rollover list where they're going to
have to get the absentee ballots out for
all
it's nearly 700 000 people now the
state's not doing that in this
particular case if there's a state
runoff
there are three counties that have the
congressional district 5 runoff election
to fill out the remainder of john
lewis's seat and early voting for that
begins believe it or not on monday
so they'll be running those elections at
the same time they're going to be
preparing for this audit
we have to get ready for certification
and then a recount and then in the
middle of that
we now look like we're going to have to
have a runoff potentially for the purdue
seat along with
the um lefler seat and the state will be
doing the rollover list for those
which again is 700 000 ballots we had to
prepare for
we worked on making sure inventories are
in place for those runoff elections
for the absentee process we encourage
the counties to go through their
inventories the state order stuff about
a month ago only just in case the
scenario presented itself
so obviously john lots of things
happening at one time these elections
directors are going to have a very good
sleep sometime after
probably january 15. yes ma'am hold on a
second
at this point we don't have any of the
numbers coming in on the keyword ballots
on that as you know they have until
tomorrow
to cure those battles stephen
well one of the issues you have is first
absentee ballots were allowed to be
submitted legally by 7 pm on tuesday
so i like this before everybody's
running the election on tuesday so you
get into wednesday then you have to do
signature verification
to assure that that ballot belongs to
the person who previously requested it
so that's one of the important things if
you want to make sure the actual human
being
who voted that ballot is the one who
requested that ballot that's a very
important distinction
of absentee ballots in georgia then they
have to go through the process
of putting them into batches then they
get scanned and when they get scanned
if there is a overvote or an ambiguous
mark on an election
it then has to be adjudicated and that
requires volunteers from the republican
democrat parties to sit together to
decide what that voter meant
and when you have larger number of
ballots it takes a longer amount of time
let me explain what the difference of
outstanding means i mean outstanding
from our vote totals they have 15
000 scanned they have 2 000 more to scan
i know they're working on it right now
as i've noted before and if you go to
the savannah
morning news they've got a good
explanation of their split registrar
versus elections
which slows that process down compared
to other states so they match them a
little bit differently and that just
takes some more time that's one of the
reasoning investigators to make sure
there's
that's the reason i'm aware of right now
we'll make sure there's nothing else
that's causing any issues down there yes
sir
have you identified any of those ballots
that have come in that you would
consider
any but first of all the secretary of
state's office does not make those
distinctions those are county level
decisions made by county elections
directors and their designates
uh any battle that came in late after 7
pm it's not that it's an illegal vote
it's no longer allowed to be counted
because it came in too late under the
law it's things like that so we will
have
an inventory of those after the election
but right now we're focusing on counting
those legal lists that we know are there
hold on emma oh you know what you've
been patient okay
when you do the risk of in the audience
yes you rescan the value are you
scanning the qr code
or the human readable text well on the
risk limiting audit there is no scanning
is only based on what a person can read
so that's what the whole point of this
is is to make sure that the outcome is
reflective of what the
individual voter who read their ballot
whose candidates to go in
is what is done yes sir um
there is a possibility now the
likelihood is not all 8 000 of those are
going to show up
but i understand that with the close
nature of especially the presidential
race those could become vital and
important but there is a cut off time
that's why we have laws that's why we
have certification times and the reason
that we have those is so we can get to
an ending
as i stated before we have to certify
this election by november 20th because
under the law we have to get the federal
runoff ballots for the senate runoffs
out by saturday to you acaba
on saturday the 21st so we can't have
anything get in the way of our timelines
on this so
it's going to be difficult for us to
make it as it is and our poll workers
our
elections directors our election staff
the center for elections
they're going to be playing a lot of
long hours to bring democracy to the
people of georgia
the only one we have right now is
because we have that monitor unfolding
there's 3 900
i don't have an answer with it we're
working with the counties to get a
handle on how many they have
obviously they have to be cured or
actually verified by tomorrow
and i don't know the codes on any of
these so right now i'm
i've really put a lot of work into the
um elections directors right now to
answer questions so
that's one i'm gonna leave for a little
bit later i would like to i'd like to
know the answer but
they're really focused on getting those
last ballots done yes
morning's ma'am and today the progress
and changes
that have taken place frankly i don't
remember the number i gave this morning
i think it was like 62 000
um i thought there were a little over 47
000 now
but there have been changes even inside
that number like i noted before the
net numbers from that one scanner from
absentee in person which early vote is
and actually while i have everybody here
just to clear a few things up
people get confused early voting and
they go online and they look for i was
i've listed having requested an absentee
i didn't early voting in person
is what they call absentee in person
so that is what they have done they
voted absentee in person so i know
there's some confusion out there so i
want to clear that up
um we feel like we're in a very good
position to have
most of it done heck we've got most of
it done now we're down to the final
percent or so
which when a race is this close
obviously everybody wants to know when's
it going to be over
the only outlying edge we have is the
certification deadlines
yes sir what answer do you have for the
presidential
my straight answer in this state with
these elections directors is they're
doing the best to make sure that every
legal vote is counted
and the outcome will be whatever the
voters of georgia have chosen and yes
it's a tight race so be patient the
outcome will be certified we'll have an
audit so we will all know that the
outcome is correct
hold on cnn what's that
you know i'm not sure how to get back to
you without that i mean my assumption
probably in the business day it's not
going to be midnight for some of these
people because we have to have people
operating in regular business hours
yes what's that
he's in meetings trying to keep up with
a lot of this stuff right now i'm the
numbers guys so i get to talk about some
of this stuff yes sir
like the jacket by the way
there is no paper trail to go back
because under the state constitution of
georgia
it is a private vote as an absentee
ballot we have a secrecy sleeve around
that
so once it is verified as having come in
the
secrecy sleeve is separated from the
individual so that when they open the
ballot they don't know
who that's tied back to so there's no
way for the person to verify it
once it's been cast every single vote
has to be looked at and examined by that
individual voter as they send it in with
the outcomes we've seen this pretty much
falls in line with everything
we've been looking at
everybody's credit for voting is there
absolutely but there's no way to there's
no physical way to tie a vote back to a
person that would lead to things like
vote buying it's the reason we don't
have we would not allow photo
photography of your ballot in
the booth what else we got yes ma'am
at this point they're going to be
looking at the process and making sure
because we anticipate with any area that
goes quote unquote late even though this
is part of the process
there will be questions raised we want
to be able to have a first-hand account
of how things were processed and what
was done on the ground
that does not include provisional
ballots because those may or may not be
counted and the other thing is the eight
thousand eight hundred ninety nine
is that just military or it's it's
uniform military overseas it could be it
could be a a expat
yes it could be under that same thing
yes john having said everything
about the members and the process and
the integrity of the system
to what degree are you aware of great
concern
for the public all across this country
and certainly in georgia about the
integrity of the foxes
concerned that maybe somehow votes are
being found
uh that are trying to rig the system and
put the system uh at their adversity and
come
well i think people's going to try to
rig a system that might have seen
something a little bit less close than
this
that's one two we have in this process
159
dedicated elections directors and their
staff who are working to get this right
they're working diligently every single
day
we have the we know how many requests
came in for absentee ballots we know how
many ballots
were received so that is that is an
outward bound so nobody could suddenly
show up with a hundred thousand extra
ballots somewhere in this state in
particular
we take security very seriously the the
entire name of our campaign for
launching this
new system was secure your vote and it's
really important
and i understand that in other states
there are questions i can only speak for
this state
and i can speak for the people of
secretary raffensberger staff
the elections directors around the state
they're going to get it right
we're going to have an audit to prove
they got it right we went for risk
limiting on it which is a little more
difficult to do than traditional audit
we're going to have a recount for
president more than likely and people
will see those outcomes
stay essentially the same the recount we
had in savannah
really proved that the scanned ballots
were the same as when a human being read
and counted those ballots so
i feel like in this state we've taken
the steps at every level
to secure that vote and make sure the
integrity of the ballot is protected
all right um yes ma'am sorry
i know they filed that lawsuit um
anything else
all right thank you all very much have a
great day oh john come on one more
we have been sending out reports about
every half an hour of the ballot counts
as they come in
uh we will try to supplement those with
county level council as well if we can
get to that point but the main thing is
balloting is continuing the ballot
processing and counting is continuing
we have the basic pool of ballots that
are there so we know the outward edge of
these things
again i said i was prayerful we would be
done today this morning
i am still prayerful for that but it has
to go tomorrow to make sure that we get
it accurately done
so be it so thanks a lot guys
[Music]
people are afraid
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
sometimes
you need
[Music]
[Music]
to fight it
including yourself